Elon Musk propose 1 milliard de dollars
à Wikipédia s'il change son nom en
dikipédia le milliardaire américain a
publié sur sa plateforme plus d'une
dizaine d'attaques contre le site
gratuit et participatif vous êtes-vous
déjà demandé pourquoi la fondation
Wikimédia veut autant d'argent ils n'en
ont certainement pas besoin pour faire
fonctionner leur site vous pouvez
littéralement garder une copie de toutes
les pages sur votre téléphone à quoi
sert donc l'argent les esprits curieux
veulent savoir Elon Musk accuse
également le site de fournir de fausses
informations sur son profil et propose
d'offrir 1 milliard de dollars à
l'Encyclopédie si change de nom en
dikipédia le mot Dick ayant plusieurs
traductions en français on vous laisse
les chercher le Mania de la tech a aussi
évovoquer le nom de wokopédia pour
dénoncer le caractère supposé trop W du
site un terme provenant des États-Unis
qui désigne le fait d'être conscient des
problèmes lié à la justice sociale et au
racisme la naissance de cette hostilité
envers Jimmy Wales à la tête de
Wikipédia viendrait d'un tweet de ce
dernier critiquant la nouvelle stratégie
de certification payante de
X